fun fact about Pete he changes his cell
phone number constantly
I don't know why that's his journey
for a long time I just kept saving him
again and again as Pete Davidson at one
point I had nine Pete Davidsons saved in
my phone and that's
just started to save him under fake
famous people's names like for a while
he was saved in my phone as Rodney
Dangerfield the week I went to rehab he
was saved in my phone as Al Pacino
I'm asleep in bed
a nurse is watching over me my phone is
next to the nurse and Pete Davidson
starts calling again
and again
but what the nurse sees on the phone is
that this unconscious patient is getting
not one but five missed calls from Oscar
winner Al Pacino so
she wakes me up
[Applause]
I go hello
oh dog I'm not doing that well
but the conversation that the nurse
thinks is happening Hello Johnny it's Al
my little boy blue I heard your ass is
in rehab how you doing dog
oh dog
I'm not doing that well